ce ne sont pas que des règles destinées
à enquiquiner les convives
c'est aussi un héritage culturel qui
remonte à la renaissance
ici on apprend qu'il faut envoyer une
invitation à dîner trois semaines à
l'avant ce qu'il ne faut pas arriver à
l'heure pour laisser le temps à l'hôte
de s'organiser et surtout qu'il ne faut
pas amené de cadeaux vous m'a invité à
dîner
j'aurai grand plaisir à vous recevoir et
ondes et dans les deux ou trois mois et
c'est ça les change sociale vous savez
que quand vous recevez on dit cette
fameuse phrase on est responsable du
bonheur de ses invités tant qu'ils sont
chez vos places à la pratique avec la
mise en place des couverts alors couteau
à droite pour 7 à gauche et cuillère il
y en a pas je sais pas si c'est conforme
aux protocoles parce qu'en fait si l
usage et puis à le protocole je veux
dire avec des règles et certains
semblent s'y connaître mieux que
d'autres
je suis chez moi donc la lande
redécouvert tout ça c'est trop lassés
code se retrouve toujours dans les
dîners mondains un savoir-vivre que
cette spécialiste à coeur de transmettre
en fait tous ces codes faut que la vie
ensemble est beaucoup plus agréable et
puis alors de plus en plus on parle de
notre art de vivre à la française c'est
ce qu'on aimerait transmettre non
seulement français mais aussi aux
étrangers
c'est réputé dans le monde entier et
c'est toujours agréable de montrer cette
partie historique de notre patrimoine
ces ateliers des bonnes manières ont
lieu tout l'été pour apprendre à briller
en société
juste avant la rentrée